it's a tuesday july 6 hiatus edition of
pft live and pft pm i'm back in the
usual position today a little change of
pace out from the dungeon no streaming
hookup the usual camera i didn't think
i'd be back in this seat until august 9
but here i am and here you are so let's
get to what's happening in the national
football league aaron rodgers packers
quarterback later on tuesday we'll be
golfing against
tom brady and phil mickelson with bryson
d chambeau i think i got all the names
right in the match the 2021 edition
and rogers had some things to say on
monday about his offseason his focus on
mental health and that's great look
sports are becoming more and more
sensitive to the reality that the
athletes are under a ton of pressure
there are all sorts of issues and
challenges that they have to deal with
all the time doesn't matter how much
money you're making you're still human
fundamentally and there are very human
issues that go along with it that's
great
but
there's still
a mystery a so-called beautiful mystery
about aaron rodgers future with the
green bay packers three weeks from today
it's time to show up for training camp
will he be there will he not be there no
one still knows what the answer that
question is and the press conference at
which he made the comments on monday
about mental health
i saw one article about it so far there
may be more but there was an item at
espn.com from ben baby with
the quotes the key quotes from rogers
about why he's focused on mental health
this off-season but i can't find the
actual press conference the full version
of it i i assume he said nothing about
what his plans are
three weeks from now because i assume
that would have been a much larger
headline than
the question of of what he was focused
on throughout the offseason because
everybody wants to know will he be back
i still think he'll be back
but
i'm i'm as in the dark as anyone else
who doesn't have true inside information
i assume his agents have an idea of what
he's going to do
i assume his fiance shailene woodley has
an idea of what he's going to do i
assume his head coach matt lafleur knows
whether or not he's going to be there
and as we suggested a week or two ago i
think some things that matt leflore said
before the ota process ended in green
bay i think based on those things he he
believes that rogers will be there
regardless we won't know for three more
weeks
vegas or at least the points bet sports
book
i i don't know that they're making a
prediction as to whether or not he's
going to be there they put the win total
back on the board for the packers
earlier this month july
at nine
i i say take the over on that
uh
because i think he will be there and if
he's there nine and eight i think
they'll be better than nine and eight if
aaron rodgers shows up now one thing
that may make it harder for them to be
as good as they were last year when they
were 13-3 or the year before when they
were 13-3 the fact that rogers
apparently hasn't done any work with his
receivers his past catchers his
teammates that he'll be if he shows up
forced to try to accelerate that process
i mean you think about it tom brady
spent a lot of time working with his
guys even though a lot of it was away
from the facility he's working with his
guys getting ready for the season rogers
my understanding hasn't had
off-site unofficial workouts with his
teammates remains to be seen whether or
not they're going to get together in the
next three weeks but roger's golfing
today i presume he's going to be at the
the american century championship pro-am
tournament this weekend that'll be
televised by nbc in tahoe and then you
got two weeks until training camp opens
how ready
will rogers be i saw video of him
golfing yesterday he still looks a
little on the skinny side is he going to
be ready to take the pounding that
quarterbacks take especially as they get
deeper and deeper into their 30s a lot
of questions
and eventually we're going to get
answers three weeks from today
the simplest yes or no question to start
the process will be answered is he going
to show up for training camp either he
will or he won't if he doesn't
then what if he does
then what because i still think deep
down
packers ceo mark murphy would prefer
that he not show up got no inside
information on that one either but
i just think that
murphy the guy who surely signed off on
the drafting of jordan love in 2020
may be ready to turn the page
maybe hoping that rogers doesn't show up
and then he becomes the bad guy
the fans are always going to line up
behind the laundry especially in green
bay where plenty of fans own a piece of
the laundry because they're shareholders
if rogers doesn't show up
he gets the brett favre treatment by the
fan base quite possibly because even
though rogers has a legitimate beef with
the packers management regarding the
jordan love thing i i don't get the
impression
that the fan base is universally lined
up behind him and chastising the team
for doing what it did because you know
what at some point he's not going to be
there they have to be ready for the
future now are they being maybe a little
overly
zealous about their preparation yeah
they didn't need to use a first round
pick last year on jordan love they
didn't need to use the fourth round pick
that was the bait for trading up they
gave up two picks a one and a four to
get a guy who stood on the sidelines all
last year and if aaron rodgers shows up
and doesn't get injured he'll be
standing on the sidelines again this
year not helping the team win a super
bowl but the bottom line is
i think rogers will be there trying to
help the packers win a super bowl and
wouldn't it be a great story if he did
as his final act with the packers win a
super bowl and walk off into the sunset
and then get traded within a month to a
team like the broncos or maybe the
raiders or maybe someone else
2018 draft wasn't all that long ago the
three quarterbacks of the five taken in
round one who have
become pass on the pass fail side
because that's all that matters the
first three years pass or fail josh
rosen fail not entirely his fault but
clearly fail sam darnold how could it
not be fail he got traded to the
carolina panthers he could still flip
that f to a p
but for now
we're not thinking about his second
contract we are thinking about second
contracts for the other three guys
taking in round one that year baker
mayfield to the browns first overall
selection josh allen of the bills
seventh overall pick and then
with the final pick in round one it was
the ravens trading back in to get
quarterback lamar jackson
who was the 2019 nfl mvp not a bad way
to cap your second season in the
national football league so now this
dance continues of who's going to get
paid who goes first i continue to
believe
that the two guys who have agents
traditional agents baker mayfield and
josh allen they want to let lamar
jackson go first we reported over the
weekend that the negotiations even
though there's a lot of confusion and i
think some incorrect reporting about
who's involved in the negotiations for
example lamar jackson's mother isn't
negotiating on his behalf jackson is the
one who's doing the negotiation and he's
being advised by others but those
negotiations moving smoothly i think
he's the first one to do the deal
i think the bills and josh allen need to
do a deal because
like jackson
i think it's clear now
that josh allen
is
a top 10 if not top five quarterback and
you do have to ride
that guy as long as you possibly can
that's the ravens attitude with lamar
jackson and i think it is or at least
should be the bill's attitude with josh
allen this is our guy
we're going to see how it goes we're
going to get a contract in place that we
believe uh is appropriate
is fair
and that sends the message this is the
guy for the foreseeable future and
beyond the ravens definitely feel that
way about jackson the bills as i said
should feel that way about josh out with
mayfield
you know there's some thought in league
circles that the browns would like to
give it one more year even though it's a
calculated risk
because let's say mayfield wins the mvp
in 2021 and
when you think about how mvp gets
determined
one seed in each conference the
quarterback of the one seed that that's
the guy who has the inside track two
guys have the inside track afc one seed
quarterback and nfc one seed quarterback
if the browns
end up
taking the number one seed and and look
the afc is very top heavy this year so
it's by no means an easy proposition but
if they end up there mayfield's got a
good shot at being the mvp and he he was
great the second half of last year as
the browns ascended
if the browns wait a year
and if mayfield ends up
being
one of the truly best quarterbacks in
the nfl it's going to cost a lot more
next year to get him signed than it
would this year
the question becomes this what would the
browns pay this year
and how close is that to what mayfield
wants mayfield has always been very
confident in himself and that's great
you need that to thrive at the nfl level
how big of a gap right now is there
between the brown's willingness to pay
and mayfield's expectations
it may just be that they can't find a
way to make the two sides come together
this year and they have to wait a year
and that's a gamble for mayfield if
mayfield says no to that bird in the
hand
that bird could shrink by next year if
he gets injured if he has a rough season
if he regresses
and the reason that this is all relevant
the two contracts done for the 2016
number one and number two overall picks
jared goff carson wentz
three years after their career started
they got their second contract two
seasons after doing those second
contracts
their teams
and look we don't even have to i mean
it's no it's a given they regret it we
don't have to put anyone under a lie
detector test to get to the truth
clearly they regret it the eagles traded
carson once to the colts and
the rams tucked jared goff into the
matthew stafford trade and
as a practical matter gave up a first
round pick to get that contract off the
books so that that is the cautionary
tale and i thought it was funny back in
may when brown's gm andrew berry said
it's not a cautionary tale those
contracts the wents and the golf
contracts it is it is and i think the
fact
that barry said it isn't is
kind of an effort to
obscure the reality that the browns are
going through that analysis very heavy
on analytics
and
when when you focus on that aspect you
understand more than any other team that
your players really are interchangeable
parts and the question becomes
if we pay baker mayfield what he wants
that's one approach the other approach
with all these great quarterbacks coming
out of college every year
could we do
dollar for dollar a lot better at the
quarterback position mayfield at
whatever his magic number is
rookie at a slotted deal for three years
before you get into what the next
round of financial compensation is
don't be surprised if it goes that way
don't be surprised if mayfield wants so
much
that the browns say as a business
proposition we're not doing it they're
facing that challenge in the coming year
with nick chubb one of the best running
backs in the nfl but you know what you
can find another nick chubb in round two
round three round four round five round
undrafted there are plenty of running
backs out there every year it's part of
the challenge and it's one of the
problems of having a great team it's
easy
to be driven by analytics and that type
of analysis when you don't have star
players when you do have star players
when fans are invested in those players
when fans have purchased the jerseys of
those players becomes a lot harder to
treat them like the interchangeable
parts that a team that is so driven by
analytics would prefer
to do
the cults
employing basic common sense when it
comes to
how much you will pay a guy and what
dollar for dollar value you get they
have been very resistant under gm chris
ballard to splurge in free agency every
year there's there's some big name guy
that we think oh the colts are going to
go do it they're going to go do it
they're going to go after this guy
they're going to go after that guy the
biggest thing they've done under ballard
the trade for deforest buckner
and they turned around and gave him a
pretty big contract after he gave up the
first round pick for him that's the
exception the rare exception chris
ballard recently said
they are not going to pay b level
players a plus money and that's what
happens right out of the gates in free
agency unless there is some guy out
there that you have to pry away from a
team that recognizes you know what we're
not going to be able to pay all these
guys on our front four we better flip
one of them and get what we can that's
why buckner was available that's why the
colts did it the usual run-of-the-mill
free agency class has a bunch of guys
who are right there out of the gates and
someone pays too much and the cults
always resist that temptation to pay too
much and they've quietly put together a
team that that continues to contend
better than we thought it would after
the sudden and andrew luck retirement in
late august of 2019. they've been
i think all in all over achieving
playoffs last year gave the bills
everything they could handle in the wild
card round and there's a good chance
they're going to be pretty good this
year but along the way they are not
going to overpay for players that is the
key that is part of the
the quality of the sport that sets the
human emotion aside and just looks at
the player rips the name off the jersey
and decides
the amount of money this guy wants and
what we get from him versus the amount
of money this guy would cost and what we
get from him and every year those draft
picks with the slotted contracts with
the certainty for three years with the
lesser money for three years at a
minimum
that's the better way for a lot of these
teams to go and that's why we see so
much of a focus now on the draft that's
the way you reload and then those guys
become your star players and then you
make a decision at some point do you pay
that star player what he wants or will
someone else pay that that potential b
level player a plus money on the first
day a free agency
one of the news items that is lingering
and percolating in the month of july how
many teams will take advantage of the
nfl's new rule allowing for a second
helmet
anyone who's going to do it for 2022
must declare their intention by the end
of this month and i mention that now
because the 49ers reportedly considering
a red helmet yes a red helmet as an
alternative helmet beginning in 2022.
the problem for a lot of the teams is
that and i'll give you the easiest
example the tampa bay buccaneers
creamsicles
and this was
either not noticed ignored or not
understood
by
the reporters who were so quick to start
saying well we'll have the pat patriot
uniforms in 2022 we'll have the
creamsicles in 2022.
the deadline
for
submitting
alternate uniforms for 2022 has already
passed so unless the buccaneers
guessed right
and assumed that they would have the
ability to use the white helmet there's
no reason
to submit
a plan for an alternate uniform based on
the creamsicles the orange and yellow
and white it would look ridiculous with
the helmet that they currently wear so
that's what's going to slow that process
down for the teams that would like to
have that throwback uniform that
requires the shirt in the jersey to go
along with the helmet for the 49ers
they're bringing back the 1994
throwbacks this year
i i just slap a red helmet on that for
next year look look there's plenty of
financial reasons for having an
alternate helmet
because you sell the alternate helmet
and
we know football football's a business
at this point we've talked about it over
and over again football's family you
know football's business and they say
football is family because it's good for
business and what's good for business is
having more stuff people can buy i'm not
i'm not faulting it i'm a capitalist
make money get paid
but
you know the consumer needs to have
their eyes wide open about what this is
about if you have a second helmet that
you wear you have a second helmet that
you sell
and that's the key and if you buy that
helmet if enough people like that helmet
that they do go out and purchase it it's
more money for the team that you're
supporting by having your two helmets
full size and miniature
base helmet alternate helmet that that's
that's
what teams have lost out on over the
past eight or nine years since the nfl
insisted on one helmet
that that cash cow is returning
as soon as next year and it sounds like
the 49ers are going to try to take
advantage of it i have no problem with
them doing it all right
let's answer some questions on this
tuesday hiatus edition of pft live pftpm
interesting question from
paul benjamin
fitzsimmons
as an old man who hates that numbers are
changing and still believes receiver
numbers should be in the 80s i've always
wondered something setting aside how it
might affect player relations in pr can
a team
arbitrarily dictate what number a player
can have or is that prohibited look i've
always been a believer and i've never
heard anything to the contrary
the team controls the numbers the team
issues the numbers the team decides who
wears what number now you know in a lot
of cases the team doesn't care
hey we got a new receiver these are the
numbers that are available which one do
you want okay give him 82 give him 12.
this year give him three if he wants it
so
i don't think teams really care all that
much but if you have an owner
who says you know i really don't like
this
single digit thing if miles simmons
would win the lottery and buy a team if
he'd end up buying the browns from the
haslems he could say because we know he
hates single-digit numbers he could say
no one's wearing single-digit numbers
other than kickers punters and
quarterbacks so i think the team can
impose its own approach
but you know the reality is yes player
relations could be an issue and at some
point you run out of numbers that's why
they passed this rule they're running
out of numbers and they have some guys
on the team wearing the same number
multiple guys in the same number the
chiefs propose this change specifically
for that purpose in order to have more
numbers available for more players
interesting question here from the pft
pm posse just because i read the
question doesn't mean i'm going to
answer it generally speaking
how many owners have you heard credible
rumors of pretty significant misconduct
about no names or identifying info what
am i what i mean what am i what am i
supposed to do with that pfd pm posse
generally speaking tell us what you know
don't name names but tell us what you
know and and this flows from my belief
that
the league went easy on washington
football team owner dan snyder last week
with its findings from the workplace
misconduct investigation
as a way to
ensure that other owners won't be held
to the same standard
by protecting snyder
they've protected themselves now i am
aware of no misconduct accusations or
investigations or allegations but you
know what
we didn't know damn thing about what was
going on with jerry richardson in
carolina until multiple individuals who
had signed confidentiality agreements
who had received settlement payments
from the panthers
to resolve potential civil claims
against jerry richardson and the team
they broke those agreements and i
continue to have
a concern about that because
when you commit to confidentiality as
part of the value you're getting to
resolve your civil claims and that's how
the sausage gets made civil litigation
it's about money 95 of the cases that
get filed are about compensation for
some
violation of someone's rights
you get extra
to agree to not say anything somebody
said something and it brought down jerry
richardson well how many other owners
out there have entered into similar
confidentiality agreements to settle
claims of misconduct that if we knew
what the misconduct was
the reaction would be
that person's unfit to own an nfl team
again i know of none but i believe
that the owners don't want to have to
worry about someone having power over
their ability to continue to own the
team by making accusations that
potentially get resolved with a
settlement agreement that comes to light
and brings down the regime that's why i
think one of the reasons why i think
they went as easy as they did on daniel
schneider and look
they handled this masterfully
they dropped that report late afternoon
on the thursday or fourth of july
weekend no one paid attention friday
saturday sunday two ridiculously slow
nfl news days as everybody enjoyed what
ended up being a very nice weekend for
most of the country and then monday for
a lot of people a holiday five days
later here we are how much is that
resonating i still think there's going
to be a delayed reaction here and i do
think that someone will be sufficiently
troubled by the fact that the nfl is
trying to conceal
the findings the factual findings that
were reached by lawyer beth wilkinson
that somebody's going to do something
about it whether it's lawsuits by former
employees whether it's
congressional curiosity that results in
a subcommittee hearing or whether it is
and a point that i made on monday
a prosecutor with jurisdiction over the
washington football team's workplace
deciding based upon the conclusions
reached by the commissioner of the
things that happened general conclusions
maybe there's a reason to put a grand
jury together
and look into what actually happened
because maybe there were some
violations of criminal laws that
occurred that would require intervention
prosecution and maybe maybe some sort of
criminal penalty
at science milk
why of all the episodes of the office is
this your favorite thanks i'll hang up
and listen and the gift is kevin
dropping
the vat of chile if i recall correctly
that was a cold open to start an episode
and i don't remember the rest of the
episode i don't remember it at all
so great cold open but completely
disconnected from the episode itself
it's not like the episode was about a
chili cook-off or
or chili recipes or anything about chili
that was just a little thing they played
at the beginning of the show and that
was it and then the show moved on to
something else again i don't remember
what else that episode was about so no i
disagree with that
uh cj newman i know you
didn't enjoy wrestling past the chief j
strongbow era but since peacock acquired
the wwe network what have you watched in
the archives that you enjoyed i went
through a stretch back during
wrestlemania month where
while i was working out i would have on
his background listening and periodic
viewing because i'm riding a bike and
playing madden so i it's it's like the
george costanza trifecta that gets me
through the hour between playing madden
and having something on my phone i can
get through the hour on the bike i watch
wrestlemania one two three four five
and i think all of six i eventually lost
interest but the first few to watch
those again fascinating and that's all
i've seen so far but but uh
the hulk hogan and the macho man and the
ultimate warrior and and just kind of
reliving those events a lot of fun
there's so much on there's such a reach
a rich library of past wwe back when it
was the wwf that's how long ago it was
plenty of great stuff out there
see what else we have another one from
cj newman remember that time
you were considering a pft pm summit
yeah that's not looking like a
consideration in 2021 how about a
virtual summit uh i'm not interested in
doing anything virtual i don't know how
interested i am in doing anything in
person either look the pandemic changed
me i assume it's changed a lot of people
and i don't know how long i'm gonna feel
this way
i got no desire to interact i got no
desire to go out i got no desire to do
anything other than be in my house
and take care of my business and do the
things that i want to do and be around
the people that that i want to be around
the only thing i do is go to the store i
like going to the store i like going to
the store because you go with a list you
get the stuff that you went with you go
home you put it away and you feel like
you got something done but at the store
now with the masks on it was kind of
easy to not interact now that the masks
are off you know i'm not going to be
impolite to anyone but i just want to
get my stuff i want to get home i want
to put it away and i want to get back to
doing what i want to do so
long story bearable
i love all of you i just don't want you
coming to my house
or anywhere else that i'm going to be
sorry but that's just the way it is we
can have our relationship through this
medium isn't that enough
i would like to think that it is next
question
uh let's see
this one i was intrigued by and i
actually did a little bit of research on
it with the recent nil rulings which
college players who never made the nfl
through injury or whatever would have
benefited and earned the most if they
could have now i've i've twisted this
question a little bit because most of
these players did make it to the nfl
tommy prothrow is the one
was it tommy or i think it was tommy pro
throw the last name was pro throw i may
be getting the first name wrong and
alabama horrible injury 2005-ish he
would have been potentially a great nfl
player he would have made a lot of money
nil from alabama or through alabama
through his stardom at alabama and and
uh he would have had that nest egg when
the injury prevented him from playing in
the nfl but guys like tim tebow johnny
manziel
peter work remember him what a star he
was at florida state you know there are
plenty of great college players who just
never resonate never make it never
can bust through that ceiling and become
nfl stars well those kinds of players
think about how much money tebow would
have made think about how much money
manzel would have made think about how
much he did make
think about how much more he would have
made if he didn't have to worry about
getting in trouble with the ncaa when he
was signing autographs off you go you
know you win the heisman as a freshman
and then you stick around for multiple
years and you make the money off of that
fame i think those are the guys to watch
going forward the guys who make an
immediate impact
heisman finalists or heisman winners as
freshman or redshirt freshman then
you've got multiple years after that
where you can live off that fame you can
sell that fame you can profit from that
fame regardless of whatever happens at
the nfl level and one of the things that
we pointed out recently the fact that
that you can make that money
while also staying in school may cause
more guys to choose to stick around for
one more year before entering the draft
all right let's see what else we have
here
steven monk
will aaron rodgers be booed by the
packer faithful if he takes the field in
a packer jersey this season i i don't
think
that they'll boo him if he's there
playing for the packers the moment he's
back the moment he's all in everything's
forgotten bygones are bygones
because
all that other stuff won't matter
if he's back in the fall now
if they struggle this year
if they aren't
13 and 3 or close to it
that's when you have to wonder
will
some packers fans say
boy if you've just been there for the
offseason program
if you've been there for mandatory mini
camp if you'd gotten together with your
teammates if you'd been more invested if
you've been more all in
maybe we'd have been better maybe this
is on you that's the risk he's taking if
he does show up because he disconnected
for so much of the off-season
you know they meet the buccaneers again
in the playoffs and tom brady and his
guys fully ready to go from
basically the day after the boat parade
and rogers
kind of blows into training camp and
says hey here i am let's go ahead let's
get ready uh that that could create some
resentment but i i don't think they're
gonna boo him as long as he's wearing a
packers jersey i just don't think that's
the way it's gonna work
let's answer a couple more here
[Music]
prod
visper
what do the seahawks have to do to get
back to winning super bowls it feels
like every year we surprise people we
and win plenty of games early but fail
to complete the job down the stretch or
in the wild card divisional round is it
a pete problem or just better talent
across the nfl well you know when when
we were going through the chris sims top
40 quarterback countdown and russell
wilson fell
sims and i kind of agreed russell wilson
is still as good as he ever was
there were just guys in the nfl now at
the quarterback position who were better
than russell wilson josh allen
patrick mahomes better than russell
wilson
and
i
they haven't been to the nfc
championship since 2014 the year that
they pulled the rabbit out of the hat
and beat the green bay packers and went
back to the super bowl
and almost went back to back
losing as everyone knows in the closing
seconds to the new england patriots they
haven't been back to the nfc
championship since that year
so
i look it's defense
that that's fallen off
and they either need to put back
together the kind of defense they had
during the two years they went to the
super bowl
or they truly do need to turn over the
offense completely to russell wilson
that's what he wants maybe that's what
they're going to do with shane waldron
last year they tried to do it the
problem is after they had enough film
six seven eight games defenses caught up
with them and they didn't pivot they
didn't have the kind of creativity that
would confound the defenses that's why
it's always important you've got a
successful offense you have to scout
that offense yourself self-scout
yourself as sims would say and make the
changes necessary anticipate how
defenses are picking up on trends and
tells and tendencies
and change
be ahead of your own offense that's what
the seahawks
likely failed to do last year and that's
going to be the challenge this year with
shane waldron and after the season
i don't know if they if they don't make
it to the nfc championship again
what happens do they trade russell
wilson does he want out
at some point do they choose between
pete carroll and russell wilson
it's hard to say because
ownership is as detached in seattle as
it is anywhere else jody allen the
sister of paul allen owns the team
vulcan management i think is the name of
the company it's vulcan something vulcan
something
kind of oversees the team
the pete carroll's pretty much in charge
of the football operation
and unless and until someone above pete
carroll
decides that they're sufficiently
troubled by where things are that
they're going to do something about it
pete carroll's still going to be in
charge
and and this is where you have to ask
yourself
for any given nfl team
what is your indicator of success
is it how much money you make
or is it how close you are to winning a
championship or winning championships
that's really
the key distinction
because if the seahawks are just one of
the many holdings one of the many
companies one of the many interests
that are under this broader vulcan
umbrella and every year they are turning
a gigantic profit you could make the
argument who cares
if they're not winning super bowls who
cares you know every team will say our
goal is to win the super bowl of of
course it is that's that's that's why
the game is fundamentally played to win
as many games as possible to position
yourself as best you can for the
postseason win the playoff games get to
the super bowl and win it but
the reality is there
they want to make money
they're here to make money
and they need to say
they want to win the super bowl in order
to make as much money as possible
because your fans need to think you're
trying to win the super bowl that gets
into the broader philosophical
discussion we've had about other teams
like the packers what's good enough in
green bay is it good enough to just be
on the porch and not kick the door in
is it good enough in minnesota
to get to the playoffs every other year
maybe win a playoff game once every four
years is that good enough
is it enough to keep the fan base
activated and engaged year in and year
out filling up the stadium
buying all the stuff including the
alternate helmet
is that enough or is there a consuming
burning desire to win as many super
bowls as possible the problem is if
that's how you define success you're
going to be pissed off
a lot because there's only one of those
trophies given out a year but all 32
teams have to make money and oh
they all are making a lot of money if
you don't believe me just wait until the
packers financial report comes out later
this year
nfl leads when is playmakers out whether
it be an audiobook version playmakers
comes out march 15 pre-sale official
pre-sale is coming
i
later this month just to give you an
idea how this process works
i wrote the thing
from i think i started on election night
and i finished it
right around inauguration and not that
that was the goal that was just kind of
how that window of time for me was
filled up
uh we've been through a round of edits
it's now in the copywriting process
where a copy editor not copywriting copy
editing or a copy editor
is pouring over all of it for typos and
anything else that needs to be cleaned
up i'll get that back i'll go through it
and then i think there's one final run
through it'll be like late august uh and
then uh it's in the can until march 15.
so uh like i said there will be pre-sale
i i think there will be an audio book i
know there's something to that effect in
the contract we talked recently about
you know the fact that i'm probably the
one that's gonna have to read the thing
which is fine which is fine i don't know
how long it would take i know how long
it takes me to read a book anyway i
don't read all that fast i want to
understand it and save it and enjoy it
i i have no idea how long it's going to
take to read about i think it's about
300 pages at least 300 pages on
on the word processing software i use so
it's gonna take a while whatever it is
we'll see how that goes what else do we
have
we got some funny people i know that
naji harris's football calf what
i don't have no idea what that means oh
there's a picture of his calf
hit not his cow but his calf
who do you have more confidence in going
forward between kylo murray and justin
herbert
that's a tough question
i think
given given
the structure around him i think herbert
and i think the charters are going to
become a very good team very quickly now
it would be better if they weren't in
the afc west with the chiefs but but
they'll find a way i think herbert's got
all the tools all the skills and i think
with brandon staley there is the head
coach
he's going to unlock the maximum
potential from justin herbert staley
recently said the offense is going to
run through herbert and it was great to
see the the trolls on twitter say well
what offense doesn't run through a
quarterback well plenty don't run
through the quarterback the idea is the
quarterback is the guy around whom the
offense is built that's what russell
wilson wants so badly in seattle the
offense hasn't been built around him
it's run the ball let's play defense and
it's rely on russell wilson when you
need to patrick mahomes the offense runs
through him that's how it's going to be
for herbert with kyler murray i think
he's got superstar potential
i i just think that
they may need a different head coach to
get the most out of him and i think this
year is so critical
for cliff kingsbury if they don't make
the playoffs this year and you can you
can already see it you can feel it kyle
murray is getting frustrated steve
kime's saying we have to cash in
while we have kyle murray under his
rookie contract you have different
players saying it's now or never
and and you consider the history of the
cardinals organization no one has
coached that team for more than six
seasons this is season number three for
cliff kingsbury i don't think he gets a
fourth if he doesn't take kyler murray
and the rest of that team to the
playoffs especially when you look at all
the changes they made this year in an
effort to get better
i think that that is probably it for
today let me check
because i did a second call
this morning and i haven't looked at
those yet
um let's see what we have here before we
wrap it up
let's see
cp7ny when is the watson situation
getting resolved and will he get traded
this close to opening week i
let me let me finish with that one
um
i
i think that
the 22 lawsuits pending against deshaun
watson can be resolved in theory at any
time and the fact that they got caught
up on the question of whether and to
what extent the outcome
and the facts and the allegations and
everything else relating to the cases
would be confidential
that tells me that they had some sort of
an understanding as to what the amounts
would be you don't get to the point
where you're haggling over
confidentiality
if you aren't even close
to a consensus on how much is going to
be paid so i think that could be dusted
off at any moment between now and the
opening of camp what i continue to
believe is that without a settlement
the nfl needs to let watson the texans
and any team interested in trading for
him know whether or not he's going to be
put on paid leave if he's put on paid
leave if he knows he's going to be put
on paid leave you show up for camp with
the texans you get put on paid leave you
make 10 million this year to not play
football unless the texans are going to
cut him which i doubt that they would do
they could also trade him from paid
leave and a team could say hey we'll
give you
we'll give you whatever you'll take
for deshaun watson and we'll pay him
this year to not play knowing that we're
going to have desean watson at some
point because he will play football
again at some point i'd be stunned if he
doesn't
he's still
quite pop
look i i don't want to set myself up for
freezing cold takes here but i'd be
stunned if he never plays football again
i'd be stunned if he doesn't play by
2022.
but either way the nfl i believe if the
cases aren't settled needs to let
everyone know before camp yes no will he
be put on paid leave if he's not going
to be put on paid leave trade market
opens and even though we're we're close
to
the point where the hay needs to be in
the barn for these teams they're gonna
go forward with the quarterbacks they
have if all of a sudden the dolphins
could get deshawn watson if the eagles
could get deshawn watson if the broncos
could get to sean watson
how do you not go at least try to get to
sean watson especially if there's a
chance that you can get him for less
than what you would get him for if
the
22 lawsuits
would be resolved they get those cases
resolved
i think we're looking at multiple
first-round picks so we'll see how the
rest of the month plays out it's one of
those things that it can happen out of
the blue any given time any given moment
it could occur we'll see how that plays
out we'll see you again hopefully
tomorrow for another edition of pft live
slash pftpm while we continue to be on
our official hiatus we'll be back on
august 9 but as you've seen if you've
been paying attention to the website we
really haven't gone anywhere even during
the slowest time of the year there's
plenty happening in the nfl thanks for
some of your time today see you again
tomorrow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports